well let's join Dominic who is live now
in Kia for us and and Dominic Russia
says that it doesn't Target uh civilian
targets the ukrainians would beg to
differ here
yeah that's Dimitri peskoff the Kremlin
spokesperson saying that to our producer
in Moscow and he's he's a man who has
lied uh frequently through this conflict
so don't take his words at face value
we've also heard from a propagandist on
Russian State tv earlier this morning
who said that NATO instructors have been
in the Target and the strike objective
had been achieved now NATO would say it
doesn't have any instructors in the
country but also uh would say if if they
were in this restaurant or in the
civilian area then the Russians seem to
be admitting that they they had targets
there and were quite happy to fire these
s-300s uh surface-to-air missiles very
big missiles seven meters long missile
far from trucks uh they have used them
in the conflicts in the past to hit
ground targets and they seem to have
been happy to fire them into the center
of a city of 150 000 people uh hitting
this pizza pizza restaurant uh damaging
a kindergarten and the Ukraine is say 65
other buildings aiming if they were at
some kind of Target erroneously would
turn out but happy to fire these
missiles into a densely populated uh
area in a way that would be guaranteed
to do this kind of damage that the
latest death toll is 10 we understand
two more two more bodies have been
pulled out of the rubble as the search
and rescue operation continued including
a fourth child 61 have been wounded so
the ukrainians and among the Dead uh two
14 year old twins Julia and Anya
aksenchenko so an absolutely tragic
event in cremator and it's a year to the
day since the Russians fired missiles
into kremenchuk into the shopping center
you'll remember that attack that left
more than 20 people there so you know
the question is is this some kind of
Twisted attempt to mark that anniversary
is it the Russians trying to change the
subject after what have been three very
embarrassing days uh in in Moscow or
were they aiming it what they believed
to be NATO instructors is what they're
saying without any care at all for the
civilians in the area